a police shooting in northern virginia
where a black man was shot
10 times is now the focus of a state
police investigation
32-year-old isaiah brown is in critical
condition after he was shot
while making a call in the middle of the
night last week
you can hear a sheriff's deputy saying
drop the gun
on the body camera footage but officials
say brown
was unarmed his family says the same
deputy had assisted brown
a short time earlier jeff begays is
following the story jeff good morning
good morning the brown family attorney
says the sheriff's deputy who fired
those shots
thought that a cordless house phone was
a gun
now the family attorney says 32 year old
isaiah brown is
fighting for his life after what the
family says are completely
avoidable errors by police
and 9-1-1 dispatch
isaiah what's going on
my brother won't let me get in my mind
the spotsylvania county sheriff's office
released the 911 call
brown made last wednesday at around 3 18
a.m
of what appears to be a domestic dispute
between brown and his brother
all right give me the gun
to make me get mad bro i'm not playing
bro
what is the problem i'm about to kill my
brother
don't kill your brother somebody need to
come here real quick
brown can be heard repeatedly telling
the dispatcher
that he does not have a weapon on him
before police arrive on the scene
can you have a gun on you no do you have
any weapons on you
no you need to hold your hands up
hold your hands up show me your hands
now
police released this body camera video
showing the tense 20 seconds
after a sheriff's deputy arrived on the
scene drop the gun
he's got a gun to his head drop the gun
now stop walking towards me
stop moving towards me stop stop shots
fired shots fired one down
show your hands shove me your hands
drop the gun drop the gun
let go the gun moments later body camera
footage shows brown on the ground
after having been shot the sheriff's
deputy can be seen
giving medical assistance less than an
hour earlier the same deputy had given
brown a ride to his mother's house where
the shooting happened
after brown's car broke down at a nearby
gas station
i'm just lost somebody's reaching out
for help regardless of what the help is
they come to help and then to end up
like this yolanda brown is isaiah
brown's sister
you know the the fact that it's the same
person who
spent 15 20 minutes plus
getting to know my brother to bring him
home you know you
you build that trust for him to have did
the good deed to do that he was actually
absolutely let down by everyone brown's
attorney david haynes
says his client complied with the
officer's orders
isaiah did everything as instructed by
the dispatch officer
raise your hands up in the air and for
the officer to make this
a terrible leap that this was somehow
a gun we know that 10 shots tragically
did hit his body but that's uh
just a totally preventable situation
the sheriff's deputy is currently on
administrative
leave which is pretty standard in cases
like this while virginia state police
investigate now there is
additional dispatch audio that the brown
family once released
it is dispatch audio from prior to the
shooting with the sheriff's deputy
they believe the family believes that
there was obviously a failure to
communicate that brown
was not armed tony
jeff uh thank you very much let the
details on this case
big sigh big sigh and just you know it's
just another one of those stories where
you just shake your head
number one looking at that body cam
video i can't tell what's going
on anything at all what's happening i'm
just going by the audio where he says
show me your hand show me your hands
fire fire fire fire and then show me
your hands how do you show your hands
when you're on the ground and
that he had just driven this person home
right i just
it's done the good deed and then shows
up very hard to make sense of this all
police shooters are not the same i think
we have to make that very clear there's
been a lot of them lately they are not
all the same they are not equal
and i do believe that the majority
police officers are there to protect and
serve
but you keep hearing these stories over
and over people are feeling so
encouraged after the chauvin verdict
that maybe just maybe
and yet you still see well we all know
we still have so much work to do
i think officers themselves are
concerned i think it speaks to the issue
that there are so many guns in america
in private hands that when an officer
shows up they have no idea who has a gun
yeah and that's a problem well they were
told on the tape you could hear them
having a conversation about the gun
about guns i could see the officer is
concerned but that's
many questions there yeah we'll stay on
let's hope let's hope that he survives